hi everyone
good morning is it morning is it lunch
time
um thank you all for your flexibility i
know we moved the briefing up a little
bit today
at 1pm the president will deliver
remarks on the administration's response
to the coup
in burma which i think that guidance
just went out but just so you all
have are aware a couple of other updates
for all of you
the president the vice president and the
secretary of treasury had a productive
and
substantive conversation yesterday with
the business leaders about the need to
urgently pass the american rescue plan
the group discussed the importance of
getting direct assistance to families
who are suffering
and there was consensus that getting
immediate help to the american people is
paramount
the president also raised his priority
to increase
wages and ensure no one who makes
minimum wage
is living below the poverty line the
business leader shared the experiences
of their own workforces and discovered
disgust sorry
discuss the challenges their employees
and customer base faced to overcome the
economic crisis
caused by the pandemic the group agreed
to work together moving forward to help
grow the economy
particularly around infrastructure
investment and help make life better for
working families
across the country another scheduling
update for all of you
this friday president biden will
continue his engagement around the
american rescue plan by meeting with a
bipartisan
group of mayors and governors here at
the white house to discuss the vital
need to get more support to their
communities
and to those on the front lines of this
fight he has proposed
350 billion dollars in support for state
and local government that means keeping
cops firefighters public health workers
teachers and other public servants
on the job in the fight against the
virus and that means getting
help to cities counties and states to
get vaccines and arms faster something
many
governors and mayors have spoken about
mayors in particular on the front lines
of this and we've seen
widespread bipartisan support from them
we're hoping even bring some of them to
the briefing here
to talk briefing room here to talk with
all of you on friday
just a couple of other updates today our
covid response team
gave an update on its progress and
sweeping action in addressing the health
crisis facing our nation
they announced the launch of five new
community vaccination centers across
texas and new york state
in texas states in arlington dallas and
houston
will collectively be able to administer
more than 10
000 shots a day in some of the hardest
hit areas in the state
teams from the federal government are
being deployed immediately to help get
those sites running
and are expected to start the week of
february 22nd so before the end of the
month
in new york sites in brooklyn and queens
will open the same week and will
together have a capacity for 6 000
shots a day this follows two sites
announced
last week and other ongoing efforts to
accelerate equitable vaccination
efforts including by increasing weekly
state vaccine supply by 25 percent
since entering office deploying federal
personnel to support vaccination efforts
nationwide and over 3.15 billion dollars
in funding to states tribes
and territories second our team also
announced member
members of its health equity task force
this is something all many of you have
been asking about
since the president took office the
president's 12
members the 12 members will bring
noteworthy backgrounds and expertise to
represent a range of racial and ethnic
groups
and other key constituencies including
children and youth educators and
students
health care providers immigrants
individuals with disabilities lgbtq
individuals public health experts rural
communities state local
territorial tribal governments and labor
unions
this board is charged with issuing a
range of recommendations to help inform
the coven 19 response and recovery
including equitable allocation of
resources and of course it will be
chaired by dr
marcella nunez smith finally
someone in here i think it was your
colleague from the ap asked last
couple days ago i should say about the
president getting covet tested and i
just wanted to provide an update um
that um the president's last covet test
was last thursday it was negative we
will venture to ensure we are providing
that information to you as it comes out
moving forward
or as it he has tested um for
uh but just so everybody has a full
assessment of why or the timeline
95 there's 95 protection from the
vaccine but it's not 100
protection so the president's doctor
believes it is reasonable and prudent
to randomly test the president every two
weeks as surveillance
and we'll keep you all updated um but
that's kind of the well there isn't cdc
guidelines that's his recommendation
uh that is it let's go to you go ahead
well thank you jen for the follow-up
there
um on two topics first being impeachment
um the president has said consistently
that he will not be watching the trial
he said so again yesterday
but yesterday the house competition
managers unveiled videos of the capitol
riot that clearly
was very moving to a lot of people it
resonated to a lot of people including
those in that chamber
is the president really not going to
participate at all in this historic
experience this national moment does he
have nothing he wants to add to those
who may have been impacted
by what they saw yesterday as part of
this trial well it may seem like some
time ago but the president has spoken
repeatedly to the events of january 6th
on january 6th he called
the instruction at the capitol an
unprecedented assault on our democracy
bordering on sedition he called said it
was unlike anything we've seen in modern
times
again when the house voted on january
13th
following that vote he he called the
events of january 6 an armed
insurrection against the united states
of america that was carried out by
political extremists and domestic
terrorists who were incited to this
violence by president trump
he has certainly not been silent uh he
won't be silent on
of course um the uh you know his
concerns about hates
rhetoric and speech and the impact that
has in society and he hasn't been
silent on the actions of the former
president uh on another matter
the cdc today announced that they find
that
there they have a study to show that two
masks are significantly better than one
in slowing the spread of coronavirus
will the white house champion the
position that americans should be
wearing to masks and is that a behavior
that will be modeled perhaps by white
house staff
well i've learned a lot about this
myself the issue of studies versus
recommendations or specific guidelines i
should say so
this was a study which was a reflection
of the importance of well-fitting masks
something that many of our health and
medical experts have talked about
it doesn't actually issue definitive
guidance
on one mask versus to mask obviously if
that's something they were to issue as
official guidance
we listened to our health and medical
experts but the study does show
that if a person has a loose fitting
mask that they should consider options
to improve that fit and this includes
nose wire nodding the earlobes on your
mask
wearing a cloth mask over a medical
procedure or disposable mask something
we do
here quite a bit so the bottom line of
that study is actually to improve
the fit of the mask and a second mask is
one of several options to be able to do
that and then just
follow up and then i'll hand off in
terms of where is the
is there a plan underway for the white
house administration
to send out masks to americans to mail
them to addresses
so americans will have their own high
quality mask when there's often
confusion as to what kind
should be worn what offers more
protection sure um
well one the president uses every
opportunity he has as he did at the
super bowl
not that he was there but in the psa to
make clear to the american people the
safety of wearing masks the impact of
wearing masks he said that it would save
fifty thousand lives more than fifty
thousand lives if americans wore them
for a hundred days
uh there are a range of options under
consideration on to how
to ensure that people who need mass the
most people who need
this type of protection the most receive
it but no decision has been no final
decision has been made
um go ahead the president's remarks at
one o'clock on burma
could you give us a little flavor of
what he's going to say is he going to
announce sanctions
i've been here long we're having such
fun together i don't think you want me
to get fired
on week three of my time here as the
press secretary uh
he will uh have more to say about
actions being taken by the united states
and
in response to the coup in burma just to
follow up he's called for the military
coup leaders to stand down
is there any indication that they are
doing that yet
i don't have a specific update on the
actions of the military leaders
obviously this is an issue that we are
following closely from here from the
state department from our entire
national security team as we've noted in
here previously but it's worth repeating
we are also in consultation and close
coordination with our
partners and allies and steps that can
be taken pressure that can be made
there's been a statement from the u.n
security council which is a significant
act as you all know
so i don't have an update on the actions
on the ground but clearly this is
on the president's mind this issue and
it's essential that we lead here from
the united states just the second topic
has the president abandoned the plan to
force the sale of tick tocks american
operations to a group that would include
oracle and walmart
i know there was some reporting on it
this morning i
i i think that you're referencing i
believe
wall street journal um so uh it's not
accurate to suggest that there is a new
proactive step
by the biden white house it looks like
there was a conflation of two ongoing
processes uh one that's through the
courts and one that is through
uh the cipheus process that goes through
the department of treasury
there is a rigorous syphilis process
that is ongoing i'm not going of course
not that you're expecting me to set a
precedent of commenting on those reviews
and process
uh but would would just stress that they
are distinct
processes um i will note broadly
speaking
that we are comprehensively evaluating
as we've talked about in here the risks
us data including from tick tock uh will
and
the rest of you at the risk of uh to us
data i should say including
from tick tock and we'll address them in
a decisive and effective
fashion uh but if we have news to
announce we will announce it uh so i
wouldn't take it
as as a new uh step lastly is there a
timetable for this review
i don't have a timetable for you um
again it's a it's a broad review
that's expanded beyond tick tock of
course from here
and i think what i was referencing in
the beginning is the fact that there are
ongoing processes through the courts
which we'd certainly send you to
uh doj and others but there's also an
ongoing uh
uh cyphus review that's happening at the
department of treasury
sure jen thank you so president biden
will be speaking at the pentagon
later today among the top issues he
inherits of course afghanistan
so will he be addressing the situation
in afghanistan
and republican senator lindsey graham
said over the weekend
it's his understanding that the troops
will not be leaving afghanistan in may
as was determined under the previous
administration is that an official
decision that president biden has made
i i don't i'm not aware of senator
graham being a spokesperson for the
administration uh i will say that
i wouldn't expect there to be an update
in his remarks today
um at the department of defense um on
afghanistan
of course this is a topic that is of
utmost importance to the president and
his national security team but i don't
have an update
on forced posture uh and i wouldn't
expect one today just to be clear no
official decision on
the troop withdrawal that was previously
determined under the previous
administration
there's no update on a change or update
on a status
force the status of the forced posture
obviously that would be something
determined
uh in consultation with the secretary of
defense so understand what you're asking
he's going there today but that's not
the focus of his trip okay if i could
just follow up with you on comments you
made yesterday about school reopenings
you said the goal was for more than 50
of schools to have some teaching
in person at least one day a week you
said you hoped it would be higher
but why is the administration setting
the bar at
one day a week why not go higher well
certainly we are not uh planning to uh
celebrate
at a hundred days if we reach that goal
uh that is
our own effort to make our own set our
own markings
bold in an umbold and ambitious agenda
for how we're going to measure
ourselves and progress but we certainly
hope to build from that even at 100 days
and from there our objective the
president's objectives is for
all schools to reopen to stay open uh to
be open five days a week for kids to be
learning
that's what our focus is on this is
simply a goal for a hundred days
a lot of schools are already doing that
and for working parents
one day a week doesn't help a whole lot
that's again the
bar of where we'd like the majority of
schools across the country to be which
they're not
at this point in time and we want to
build from there and it really
depends it differs from school district
to school district part of the reason
that there is funding
in the american rescue plan is to ensure
that school districts that
don't have the funding they need to
ensure they are equipped to reopen
to meet that bar and exceed it are able
to do exactly that
go ahead hey i want to pick up one of
jonathan's comment on the president or
question on the president
not engaging on impeachment indulge me
sure
always happy too how should
the american public interpret the
president's silence
on this is he not invested in the
outcome of this trial or is he
the american public should it should
read it
as his commitment to delivering on
exactly what they elected him to do
which is not to be a commentator on the
daily developments of an impeachment
trial
but to push forward an american rescue
plan that will put people back to
that will ensure people are back to work
get the assistance they need get
shots in arms reopen schools that's what
they asked him to do and that's what
he's focused on doing every day
might he address it when it's wrapped
well he did put out a statement at the
conclusion of the house
trial so i'd certainly keep that option
open and he was obviously asked a
question as you referenced yesterday
about it and
reiterated that where his focus is and i
expect that will be his focus for the
coming days
one housekeeping thing house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
is indicating that he hasn't heard
directly from president biden
and that he reached out on january 8th
and has yet to hear back from the
president directly
why is president trump pardon me wife
president biden
not engaging i won't tom you called him
president trump why is he not engaging
with
kevin mccarthy directly well i can
assure you that senior members of our
team are in close consultation and in
touch
with senior members of of congressman
leader mccarthy's team
i don't have any additional calls to
read out for you other than to
repeat or reiterate that the president
is open to and committed to speaking
with a range of democrats and
republicans
as is evidenced by the people he's
brought here to the white house and he
picks up the phone on a daily basis and
calls people but
i don't have any calls to leader
mccarthy to read out for you today
go ahead two topics first of all what
does president biden think about the
dallas mavericks owner
mark cuban deciding to indefinitely stop
playing the national anthem before
his national basketball association
games well i
i haven't spoken with the president
about the decision by mark cuban on the
dallas mavericks
or the i should say the national anthem
but i know he's incredibly proud to be
an american
and has great respect for the anthem and
all that it represents
especially for our men and women serving
in uniform around the world
he'd also say that of course that part
of the
of pride in our country means
recognizing moments where we as a
country haven't lived up to our highest
ideals which is uh
often and at times what people are
speaking to
when they take action at sporting events
and it means respecting the right of
people
granted to them the constitution to
peacefully protest that's why he ran for
president
in the first place and that's what he's
focused on doing every day
and then on schools when president biden
talked for the last couple
months particularly during the
transition about reopening schools
within the first 100 days why didn't he
ever mention the small print
that that was just going to be for one
day a week as the goal
well again the president uh made uh set
a goal
of reopening the majority of schools
within 100 days and when you asked what
that meant i answered the question
so uh we are uh that is the that is not
the
ceiling that is the uh that is the bar
we're trying to leap over and exceed
and as i said in response to christian
kristen's question
the president wants to not just open
schools he wants them to stay reopened
he wants kids to be back in school
learning five days a week
he wants everybody parents to feel safe
teachers to feel safe
that's why he asked his department of
education and the cdc to work together
on guidelines that's why he's put
funding proposed funding in the american
rescue plan because he knows
that's not going to happen on its own
it's going to need uh some assistance to
make it make it reality is there a
thought that this
goal though that you guys are setting
for the first 100 days is
more of a dry run for next year because
100 days from january
20th april 30th that's when a lot of
schools are getting ready to close for
the year anyway
well it just happens that january 20th
is when every president is inaugurated
so we can't change that
and a hundred days we felt was a period
of time a measurable period of time
where we could set a goal measure
yourself against hopefully
leap way past that goal uh you know
that's always our objective
and then build from there and you're
right schools won't be in session for
the summer but
this is a pandemic we're working to get
under control
making progress every month and we're
certainly hopeful that things will be
uh more kids will be back in school five
days a week as quickly as it can safely
happen
and then just one more for one of our
colleagues who cannot be here because of
social distancing guidelines
uh what do you say to teachers who are
nervous about going back into the
classroom without being fully vaccinated
well we say to teachers we want you to
be able to go back to school and
go back to school safely and you know
the president is married to a teacher
dr biden he's known uh many thousands of
teachers throughout his career
uh he listens to them we all we all
engage with a range of groups about
their concerns about
what their objectives are most teachers
will tell you they want to be in the
classroom
and they want to be there with their
students especially of younger kids and
do that in person learning they want
that too they want to do it safely
we're waiting for the cdc guidelines we
are those will be the first guidelines
that will be
coming from the federal level that will
outline uh
recommendations based on health and
medical experts we're waiting for those
uh we're hopeful that those will give a
sense to school districts across the
country on the steps that they can take
to
increase the safety in their schools it
will be up to school districts but
that's really the next step here
we want schools to open but we want them
to open safely and we want teachers and
parents
to all feel that uh go ahead mike um
thanks jen if i could talk to you a
little bit about the sales campaign
that that you've talked about to to um
pass the
the kogud relief package um and the
and the and the covid uh vaccination
effort um if you compare
to the obama administration when he was
trying to sell
the uh health care uh obamacare
affordable care act
um the president went around the country
um
held law very long very involved town
hall meetings there's obviously coveted
restrictions but the president
president biden seems seems willing to
travel now he will be going on his
second
trip on air force one uh next week and
so you know why aren't you guys using
that opportunity to at least
you know get out to the to the american
people and
sell the the plan a little bit more
aggressively
and he seems to be just staying here and
then
second on the on the vaccination in a
sort of related way
um you know once the website was fully
up
for for obamacare there was a massive
multimedia campaign
tv ads um you know you worked with
partners to
to sort of get out there into like
underserved communities to
you know to get people to sign up where
is the similar effort
uh to get people vaccinated um there
will be a similar effort we've just
we've only been here three weeks it
takes some time to get a
paid media campaign off the ground we
want to do that
in an effective manner we're not we're
not waiting or delaying we obviously
just announced
the equity task force today all of these
individuals are
experts represent different parts of the
country and different communities in the
country who are deeply impacted
we expect to have many of them out there
communicating broadly
we've done dozens and dozens and dozens
of interviews
with senior administration officials
with cabinet officials to communicate
about the american rescue plan
the president's been out talking about
it nearly every day
so we have not held back from using the
bully pulpit of the presidency to
communicate with the american public
he will be out next week as you as you
mentioned and i expect he will be
out more in the weeks ahead to
communicate effectively
and directly with the american public
but a little different from the
affordable care act um what we're doing
in part it may be what's the components
of what are in the plan
uh reopening schools getting vaccines
and arms ensuring that americans who
don't have food
uh have or have you know concerns about
putting food on the table have
money to get through this period of time
is working more than 70 percent of the
public in almost every poll supports
this package
so uh we are certainly out there
everybody's focused on this every day
selling it um and the public uh seems to
like what they're hearing
but our job is not done we need to get
it across the finish line so why the
president will be traveling and others
will be out there
even more in the weeks ahead and then on
one other topic um
the president put forth on the first day
a comprehensive immigration
proposal legislation that would uh that
would wrap a lot of things into one bill
there seems to be support in the
advocacy community
immigration advocacy community now for
moving ahead with components of that
separately both for dreamers perhaps for
ag workers
does the president support splitting
that effort up uh you know while
you know while they're you know
essentially while the the bigger package
is being worked on
does he support going ahead and would he
sign into
in the law if they got past the smaller
pieces or does he want
to put that off and wait for the bigger
effort well as you know mike from
following this closely the
formal bill has not been proposed yet on
capitol hill
the president proposed it with three key
pieces of it because he felt they were
all important including
investing in smart security providing a
pathway to citizenship for
11 million undocumented immigrants and
also
addressing the root causes uh that are
causing people to flee their home
country something he
worked on even as vice president so it
hasn't even been formally proposed i
think we're going to wait for that to
happen before there's
uh you know readouts or our
engagement on what is looking like it's
going to happen on capitol hill but
we'll see what happens
um go ahead uh two questions please um
in india twitter has shut down hundreds
of accounts
from people who criticize the government
is this is the white house concerned
about this crackdown on free speech
by the modi government and to what
extent does this
impact the us india relationship and
your administration's indo-pacific
strategy
i know that my colleagues at the state
department have spoken to this more
extensively and i would certainly point
you to them of course we
always have concerns about crackdowns on
freedom of speech freedom of expression
happening around the world and when it
doesn't allow people to communicate and
peacefully protest
but i would point you to the state
department for more specifics and then
the second question
um is on the on this
chip short shortage that has now moved
beyond just automakers a lot of
automakers have shut down production
obviously they need the chips to come in
from asia you're
planning to do a broad supply chain
review
uh presumably including these chips
what does that mean does the white house
consider these parts essential
and are you interested at all in uh
creating incentives for chip makers to
make them in the u.s because
there's a lot of everything basically
relies on them right
absolutely that supply chain is
essential um this kind of flows into
both the national economic the economic
team and the national security team
let me talk to them and see if there's
any more specifics on our plans for
incentivizing production here in the
united states but uh thanks jen
i wanted to ask if you could share more
about the trip to wisconsin why
wisconsin
is he going to be doing more uh you
alluded that he'd be doing some outreach
uh can you talk about what kind of
outreach he'll be doing
is actually on the rescue plan but if
you could uh will he be meeting with
first responders
uh people in the communities can you
talk about that a little bit sure and
the
specifics are still coming together but
i'll i'll tell you what's knowable at
this point in time
you know the president is going to
wisconsin obviously it's a state where
you know many people have been impacted
by covid and many people have been
impacted by the economic downturn
uh and he always enjoys traveling and
engaging directly with people so
while he's there he'll do a town hall um
and that's an opportunity to
hear directly from people about uh how
the dual crises are impacting them
in terms of other events and stops he'll
do while he's there that's the schedule
is still kind of coming together and
being finalized
i'm myanmar burma um in burma you know
the economy is really weak
uh it's shrinking there's covid i mean
the question i have is
is would sanctions beyond uh sanctioning
the generals really help
uh in any way help in terms of change
the behavior
well or just hurt regular people in the
country
well you know we'll wait for the
president to actually announce the
specific details which i know will
happen more later this afternoon
but part of our effort is not just
unilateral action from the united states
but also
working with our partners and allies
including in the region to
determine the right ways to put pressure
on and have engagement
as i noted earlier there was obviously
the statement from the u.n security
council
permanent members there is ongoing
discussions and talks
with our partners and allies in asia and
europe
and you know there's certainly a
recognition that this will need to be a
coordinated effort
on immigration i know on monday you
talked about kind of working out
uh the priorities national security
threat recent entries
there's more reports of you know growing
number of people
arriving on the border um
how closely is president biden watching
this
obviously attacking the root causes
of this migration is something that he
knows well that he's worked on for a
long time but what about in the short
term what steps are going to be taken
uh to confront this issue because more
incumbent
so we don't have a repeat of things that
we have had in the past which
obviously president biden is very
familiar with sure he's certainly
following it closely uh but obviously
um defers to the leadership and the
guidance of
his secretary of homeland security ally
mayorkas who is now confirmed been in
office in his role for
just over a week now obviously is comes
to that job with a great deal of
experience uh working on these issues
including during
challenging times but since you gave the
media opportunity i mean one of the
things we are certainly doing
is communicating that due to the
pandemic
and the fact that we have not had the
time as an administration to put in
place
a humane comprehensive process
for processing individuals who are
coming to the border
now is not the time to come and the vast
majority
of people uh will be turned away asylum
processes at the border will not occur
immediately will take time to implement
uh and as dhs and cbp have said
um you know when long-term uh you know
this is uh
uh you know there have been incredibly
narrow and limited circumstances where
uh individuals have been um uh have come
in
uh to the country awaiting uh for uh
their hearing but
the the vast majority have been have
been turned away
and so this is not the time to come and
you know this is obviously an emotional
issue
for many of us who've worked on this in
the past for the president himself
but we need time to put in place and
partners to put in place
a comprehensive process and system that
will
allow for processing at the border of
asylum seekers but also
uh you know providing a pathway to
citizenship for immigrants who are in
the united states
um go ahead thank you jen um jim murray
who's the head of the nevada
coded task force has proposed making
nevada
have an elite level of health and safety
measures and he said
that by fall he thinks there'll be
enough shots and arms that there'll be
fans and seats a variety of venues
sporting venues concerts stuff like that
do you think that that is possible and
is that a priority for the
administration
well i think the president said during
his super bowl interview that he
certainly hoped that next year at this
time
we would all be watching the super bowl
at parties and the stands would be full
uh our but we deferred our health and
medical team who look at the entire
country and i'm not sure if this
individual is just looking at nevada or
looking at the entire country
and what their guidelines and their
guidance offers us
we know that we will have enough
vaccines to provide them to
the american people uh by the end of the
summer
but a vaccine is not a vaccination and
in order to get to a place where we are
returning back to normal
uh we need to uh ensure that those
vaccines are made and
or turned into vaccinations and that uh
you know the vast ma
that a large swath of the american
public is vaccinated
uh but obviously we we defer to our
health and medical team working for the
federal government
uh here no disrespect to the individual
you mentioned
uh go ahead yeah um does the white house
have a position
on the uh prosecutors opening up cases
in georgia on
efforts to subvert the 2020 election
i'm not i have not followed this closely
i would uh likely send you to the
department of justice for any comment on
it and
uh on the hhs secretary secretary
desmond um there are uh
plans on the part of republicans to uh
paint him as taking actions and
supporting actions in california that
have been punitive
to people there that the state has been
overly aggressive what is the
what is your position on that with uh as
far as it
goes with uh becerra
tell me a little bit more about your
question what is your response to the
idea that he uh
that he has stepped in and taken actions
in california
that uh that have been overly uh
aggressive
and that he should take bear some blame
for
the problems that the state is having
okay
well first i would say that the
president nominated attorney general
becerra because he felt he was exactly
the right person to lead the
department of health and human services
at this time
and that his work on a range of issues
including
and working to pass the affordable care
act including his defense of the
affordable care act on a number of cases
in california we're certainly part of
that uh decision
uh and and frankly it is disappointing
that
congress the senate is delaying any
further
in confirming his nomination at a time
when thousands of people
are dying every day of a pandemic and
people need leadership
at the top of an agency that has an
important role to play
go ahead thanks jen i want to ask you
questions on two fronts here
um first off you know it's been over a
month since the january 6
capital attack and we have not received
any kind of public briefing
from the capitol police a lot of people
have raised concerns about that
does president biden want to see that
kind of briefing
and also on a similar note what does he
think about
efforts from such as congressman jamal
bowmans
to establish a congressional
investigation or commission
into the capital attack we certainly
leave the determination about whether
there's a congressional investigation
up to members of congress i've seen that
proposal obviously there are
others who would need to support that to
move it forward and i know a number do
uh in terms of uh the the timeline of a
briefing from the capitol police
um you know i would again uh refer to
them on the timeline uh we of course
here in the federal government there's
an ongoing investigation as you know
out of the department of justice and i
defer to them for any reports or updates
from there
a second question um you know obviously
the president is going to be addressing
the coup in myanmar today
um you know he's i'm assuming speaking
out against it and taking action there
um you and secretary of state lincoln
have talked about how
the january 6th attack you know makes it
i think
the secretary of state's at a greater
challenge you said it will take some
time for america to gain
it's its status as a beacon of
leadership again uh
as we address this how important is it
to have accountability for the capital
attack
including potentially impeachment as we
want to you know
spread democracy abroad well i think
what secretary
blinken and i were both referring to is
the fact that
uh in order to project to other
countries around the world that there
should be a protection of democracy that
there should be freedom of speech that
there should be
freedom of expression we have to conduct
ourselves in that manner from here
and the pieces we have control over
are what the president of the united
states does what the secretary of state
does and how we all conduct ourselves
from this administration
he has spoken as i started the briefing
talking about to
his views on the horrific events of
january 6th and the fact that it was
an attack on our democracy here he has
he made those statements because that's
how he felt and also it's important to
make that clear to the public and to the
world but in terms of what steps will be
taken from here we leave that to the
senate
obviously we're calling what happened in
myanmar do you think that's an accurate
description for what happened on january
6th
i'm not going to give any new
definitions there's there's obviously a
process that's ongoing i'm sure you'll
all be watching today as the senate
proceeds with the hearings i appreciate
your creativity though uh go ahead in
the back
um the iranian-backed booty rebels
attacked saudi arabia today
and abner the coalition called it a war
crime um does this undermine the
president's effort to end the war in
yemen and
are you putting too much faith into in
the houthis rebels intention to get into
the negotiation
well thank you nadia let me first say
that we condemned the houthi attack
today
at the abba international airport in
saudi arabia civilian airport
the attack coincides with special envoy
lender king's
first trip to the region and his efforts
to bring a lasting
peace to yemen that will ease the
suffering of the yemeni people
the houthis meanwhile continually
demonstrate a desire to prolong the war
by attacking saudi arabia
including attacks on citizens and we
will continue
our diplomatic outreach and engage with
various stakeholders including members
of congress
humanitarian aid organizations the un
special envoy
and others to bring a negotiated
settlement to end
the war as president biden has said we
are stepping up our diplomacy to end the
war
as i said i should say as he said last
week at the state department and the
main
focus of our efforts will continue to be
uh
on the on diplomacy to end the war via
the u.n led process
to impose a ceasefire open humanitarian
channels
and restore long dormant peace talks we
believe that remains the best path
forward
thank you i have a quick question on
iran some reports indicating that you're
considering baby steps to get back into
the negotiation
is this on the table is this something
that administration is considering at
the time
did you say baby steps i'm sorry the
masks make it hard to hear
uh you know the president's focus is on
um reiterating what he did last weekend
which is that uh
in order to move forward iran needs to
comply with the
outlines of the jcpoa and the agreement
that was
formed just a few years ago in terms of
any additional
steps under consideration i don't have
any update on that
go ahead thanks jen um i wanted to ask
you about the budget which i know it's a
little early to be thinking about but
it's never too early to talk about the
budget
skinny budget all sorts of budgets can
you lay out a timeline for us
of when to expect to see the president's
first budget
and my second question is does the
president plan to cut his proposal for
cut defense spending or propose to cut
defense funding
as you know our nominee to lead the omb
uh
just had her hearing yesterday and
hopefully she'll be in place
soon but there was there were some
challenges that came about
during the transition in terms of a bit
of intransigence from the outgoing
administration and lack of cooperation
as it related to
omb on the budget process so we expect
there to be a delay in the first in the
release of his first budget i don't have
an exact timeline of when that will be
though
would we see an outline or something i
mean i know the budget's a thick
document but would you see an outline
before
that or what are you thinking i don't
have anything to preview yet for you
i can talk to our friends or connect you
directly with our our colleagues at omb
and see if there's anything more
specific they can preview for you at
this point in time
thank you sure go ahead in the back yes
uh thank you john
um on iran as well
does the administration welcome any
role that its allies in the region can
play
in order to help facilitate uh
talks with iran or bring it back to the
uh table i mean
general mckenzie said on monday namely
about qatar when you consider the
problem with iran they have a large role
to play in that um does the
administration
consider qatar as a potential maybe a
role player
and bringing iran back to the table and
knowing that
uh both the national security advisor
sullivan and the
elianza and boy ramali they both spoke
with the kazar permanent
well the way to move things forward
is for iran to come into full compliance
with its obligations
under the jcpoa and if they do that the
united states would do the same and then
use that as a platform to build a longer
and stronger agreement
that also addresses other areas of
concern so that's really
the ball is really in their court to
take those steps and whether there are
roles of
other countries in the region obviously
uh in any of these
um uh you know if we were to reach that
stage uh
consultations with countries in the
region would be a key part of that
process but we're certainly not there
yet
and also de-listing the houthis from the
the terror list other than the
humanitarian assistance does it
have any strategic significance
is the administration willing to enter a
dialogue with the houthis in order to
end the war in yemen
in a peaceful way i know there have been
some reports but i don't believe my
colleagues at the state department have
confirmed anything about d-listing so i
would point you to them for
any confirmation or specifics and any uh
any of the reasoning
is the administration going to do that
anytime soon
again i'd point to the state department
they have not even they have not even uh
spoken to
uh these reports go ahead mike one quick
question i know the
speaker hasn't yet set a date but i
assume we all expect
a joint address to the to congress um in
the next few weeks has the president
started
uh the process of both thinking about
what he wants to say personally and also
the
sort of inter-agency collection of
information that the
that a president normally does to these
things interagency collection doesn't
make it sound that interesting uh
discussing with experts all the ideas
they have to put americans back to work
we have um i don't have any update on on
a date um
obviously there are um you know there
the impact of covid
includes the fact that it that it is
challenging to envision how you'd have
500 people
um in an attendance at a joint session
but obviously
um remote is a remote speech possible
there are a range of
people there are other range of options
under discussion we're engaged that i
don't have any updates for what it will
look like or when it will
when it would be but i can say that you
know the president is eager to
lay out more specifics of his build back
better agenda
and he is in ongoing discussions with
a range of stakeholders in congress and
the administration
outside about what that's going to look
like and he mentioned that when he gave
his
joint not joint session speech sorry we
weren't in he wasn't in office yet but
when he gave his prime time address a
couple of weeks ago that that would kind
of be the next
step um so he's you know always
discussing with experts and policy
experts what that would look like but
i don't have anything on the timeline or
what the format would look like does he
want
does he want the american recovery plan
to be passed before he delivers that
speech
you know he wants the american uh rescue
plan to be uh to be it's okay uh to be
the arp you can call it sometimes it's
easier um to uh
be passed as quickly as possible he
certainly as having served in the senate
for 36 years he knows that there's
a process that needs to take place as
you know it's working its way through
the committees in the house then it will
go to the senate
that takes a little bit of time just by
the nature of the important work that
happens
he's pleased with the progress and the
urgency he sees from the house and
senate but
in terms of a specific date for his next
speech or next proposal i just don't
have anything to preview for you
thank you everyone
you